[MUSIC]
Exceptional leaders,
the ones who come to mind when you think
about people you admire is
that they are known for
continuing their development
throughout their lives.
Folks who take a growth mindset,
see the challenges they're
facing as something that they
could develop enough to achieve or
overcome or master or learn from.
So that a failure from a growth mindset
perspective is an opportunity to learn.
The typical approach is to be judgmental,
to think of what's happening
as somehow inevitable, and
then to worry about assigning blame for
all those things that are going wrong.
If we can develop more of a growth
mindset, we can do a much better job
of creating in ourselves a set
of capabilities that can make
us more successful precisely because
we've run into difficulties in the past.
So at all levels,
exceptional leadership for
you as an individual, for the organization
of the people you touch there and for
the world all have to do with whether or
not you take a developmental approach or
a judgemental approach.
How do your actions as a leader
affect the growth mindset of others?
What can you do to make it so
that your workplace is more
developmental and less judgemental?
>> Question your assumptions and
explore new approaches to leadership.
Explore Stanford's upcoming programs.
[MUSIC]